Salut les Épicurieuses
et les Épicurieux.
Vous avez vu où je me trouve ?
Dans un endroit exceptionnel,
je suis au Palais Garnier.
Bon, je vous avoue que je connais un peu les lieux.
C'est ici que nous avons tourné la vidéo
pour célébrer le million d'abonnés
de la chaîne Épicurieux.
En même temps...
Je suis à peine rassuré,
on raconte que les lieux seraient hantés
par un fantôme.
Le Fantôme de l'Opéra.
Alors, existe-t-il vraiment ?
Toujours est-il
qu'il a sa loge ici.
Allez, suivez-moi,
on part à sa recherche.
Ce personnage hanterait
les sous-sols de l’Opéra,
et serait à l’origine de plusieurs drames…
C’est l’écrivain français Gaston Leroux
qui le rend populaire.
Il apparaît pour la première fois
en 1909
dans un feuilleton publié
dans le journal “Le Gaulois”,
puis, un an plus tard,
devient le héros d'un roman.
Le succès est tel qu'il sera adapté
dans le monde entier :
21 pièces de théâtre lui seront consacrées.
7 films et 16 comédies musicales.
Il se passe
des choses bizarres ici...
Mais s'agit-il d'une invention ?
Eh bien pas si sûr, car l’écrivain
s'inspire de faits bien réels,
des événements troublants
qui vont semer le doute.
Le 28 octobre 1873,
un terrible incendie se déclare,
non pas au Palais Garnier
mais au conservatoire de musique
de la rue Le Peletier,
qui se situait tout près d'ici.
Le bâtiment est entièrement détruit
et l'incendie fait de nombreuses victimes.
Ernest, un jeune pianiste prometteur,
est grièvement brûlé au visage.
Totalement défiguré, il se serait réfugié
dans les souterrains du Palais Garnier,
alors en construction,
avant de disparaître
sans laisser de traces.
La légende raconte qu'il y aurait achevé
la marche nuptiale
qu’il était en train de composer
pour sa fiancée,
morte dans l'incendie
et avec laquelle il devait se marier
quelques jours plus tard.
Fou de chagrin,
le jeune homme aurait hanté
les lieux de ses cris déchirants...
Voilà qui fait forcément penser à Erik,
le fantôme imaginé par Gaston Leroux,
lui aussi est musicien,
lui aussi vit dans les souterrains
et lui aussi est défiguré.
Pour dissimuler son visage,
il porte toujours un masque :
noir dans le roman,
blanc au cinéma,
pour contraster à l'image...
Erik ?
Erik !
Avec ce premier drame,
la légende du Fantôme de l'Opéra
est en marche.
Désormais, chaque nouvel événement
inexpliqué lui est attribué :
c'est le cas lorsque le cadavre
d'un machiniste est retrouvé
sous l'Opéra...
Ou bien lorsque la chanteuse suédoise
Christina Nilsson jure avoir entendu
une voix mélodieuse l'appeler durant la nuit.
Elle affirme même avoir déjà
aperçu plusieurs fois
un homme mystérieux dans sa loge.
Cet ange de la musique,
comme elle l'appelle,
portait une cape noire
et un masque sur le visage.
On retrouve ces événements inexplicables
dans le roman de Gaston Leroux.
Mais le drame le plus saisissant
s'est déroulé dans cette salle,
le 20 mai 1896.
Ce soir-là, en pleine représentation,
un contre poids de 700 kg
servant à maintenir
l'énorme lustre,
tombe, suite à la rupture d'un câble.
Il s'écrase sur la tête d'une spectatrice,
Mme Chomette, qui meurt sur le coup.
C'est la stupeur.
Une enquête est aussitôt diligentée :
elle révèle, sans le moindre doute,
qu'un incendie est à l'origine de la catastrophe.
Mais...
Cette explication ne satisfait pas
tout le monde.
Beaucoup sont persuadés
que c'est un coup du fantôme.
Preuve de ce qu'ils avancent,
la victime était assise dans un fauteuil
portant un numéro maudit :
le numéro 13 !
Gaston Leroux n'hésite pas à reprendre
cet événement dans son roman.
Son fantôme menace même de faire tomber à nouveau
le lustre si le directeur de l'Opéra ne lui verse pas
la somme de 20000 francs par mois.
Son fantôme aimait l'argent.
Et c'est toujours sur la 13ème marche
du grand escalier qu'en 1932,
un petit rat du ballet aurait atterri
après une terrible chute.
Selon la légende, un éclat,
toujours visible sur la marche,
daterait de l'accident.
Décidément, le nombre 13
ne porte pas chance au Palais Garnier,
à tel point qu'il n'existe pas
de loges d'artistes portant ce numéro.
En revanche, dans la grande salle,
une loge spectateur
suscite l'attention de tous :
la loge numéro 5.
On y est !
C'est la loge du Fantôme de l'Opéra.
C'est écrit dessus.
Ici, la fiction rattrape la réalité.
Malgré sa position idéale
pour profiter du spectacle,
aucun spectateur, dit-on,
ne s'y aventure jamais.
On tente ?
Dans le roman, cette loge
est toujours réservée,
mais elle n'est jamais occupée...
Sauf, peut-être, par le fantôme !
Voilà de quoi entretenir le mystère,
D'autant que la malédiction
du Fantôme de l'Opéra
semble se poursuivre aujourd'hui...
À Broadway, en 1986,
en pleine représentation
de la comédie musicale
consacrée au Fantôme,
un grand chandelier se brise
et manque de blesser des spectateurs.
On passe à deux doigts de la catastrophe.
Le 25 septembre 2016,
c'est à Paris, au Théâtre Mogador,
qu'un incendie se déclare
juste avant la toute
première représentation...
Le spectacle est reporté et finalement,
il n'aura jamais lieu.
Est-ce le dernier coup du célèbre
Fantôme de l'Opéra ?
Rien n'est moins sûr...
Mais cette histoire continue de passionner
de nombreuses personnes aujourd'hui encore.
Tenez, en 2018, un escape game
a même été organisé
dans les couloirs du Palais Garnier,
le but était de débusquer
le célèbre fantôme.
Les participants l’ont-ils trouvé ?
[chut]
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout,
c'est vraiment le meilleur soutien
que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne.
J'espère qu'elle vous a donné
envie de lire le roman de Gaston Leroux
et de venir au Palais Garnier
pour le visiter ou assister à une représentation.
Qui sait ?
Vous y croiserez peut-être
le Fantôme de l'Opéra.
En attendant, n'hésitez pas à laisser
un pouce bleu
et à vous abonner à la chaîne pour rejoindre la grande famille
des Épicurieuses et des Épicurieux.
À bientôt !